skeptischer blick in die zukunft
wirtschaftsinstitute senken ihre
konjunkturprognose letzte sbr exit
angebot premierminister johnson will die
eu unter druck setzen
die ganze blatt
die goldene stimme aus prag verstummt
schlagerlegende karel gott ist tot
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster wir konnten zu einem etwas
kürzeren nachrichtenüberblick was im
sport wichtig ist wenig später von
norbert lehmann ein wunder von mir die
weltweiten handels konflikte und der
drohende braig cit belasten die deutsche
wirtschaft die folge das wachstum
verlangsamt sich so die prognose der
führenden wirtschaftsinstitute an einer
rezession schreibe man gerade so vorbei
die wirtschaftsforscher korrigieren die
zahlen für das laufende jahr nach unten
von bisher 0,8 auf 0,5 prozent
auch für 2020 senken die experten ihre
prognose deutlich von 1,8 auf 1,1
prozent die arbeitslosenquote werde sich
im nächsten jahr von 5 auf 5,1 prozent
erhöhen
mehr von patricia wiedemeier in
hohenlohe in baden württemberg stellt
die firma ziehl abegg hoch moderne
lüftungssysteme her technologieführer
sind sie derzeit noch läuft das geschäft
gut aber die aufträge kommen immer
spärlich herein
die diskussion zwischen usa und china
ist bestimmt nicht förderlich im moment
sondern das reduziert natürlich das
geschäft jeder ist vorsichtig ein tweet
von dem herrn frankreich das die börsen
einknicken es herrsche allgemein große
unsicherheit so die forscher bedingt
durch die exit und weltweiter
handelskonflikte dennoch das sei keine
rezession höchstens ein abschwung vor
allem in der deutschen
automobilindustrie
wir schreiben so an der rezession vorbei
aber also wir sind nicht drin und
geraten
nach unserer prognose auch nicht daran
das ist überhaupt noch wachstum gebe
seit dem privaten konsum zu verdanken
ein umfangreiches konjunkturpaket seien
nicht nötig aber ein festhalten an der
schwarzen null als selbstzweck wäre
allerdings grundfalsch dem abschwung
hinterher zu sparen verschärft die
probleme neue schulden in geringem maße
wie sie die schuldenbremse erlaube
müssten genutzt werden um die wirtschaft
anzukurbeln
deutliche worte die der finanzminister
und die union mit sicherheit nicht gerne
hört
für firmen wie viel arbeit bleibt die
unsicherheit langfristig planen das sei
derzeit nicht drin personal und
investitionen werden reduziert vorläufig
zumindest
beunruhigende nachrichten für europa und
den welthandel kommen aus genns es geht
um rechtswidrige subventionen für den
flugzeugbauer airbus
deswegen dürfen die usa jetzt ganz
offiziell strafzölle auf eu importe in
milliarden-höhe verhängen
das entschied die
welthandelsorganisation wto gleich
sprechen wir mit unserem korrespondenten
in brüssel
vorher eine kurze erläuterung von david
sauer airbus und boeing teilen den markt
für passagierflugzeuge fast unter sich
auf es ist das größte duopol der welt
airbus ist ein europäisches
gemeinschaftsunternehmen deutschland
großbritannien frankreich und spanien
hatten airbus günstige milliardenkredite
gewährt unter anderem für das prestige
projekt a380
die welthandelsorganisation wto sieht
darin unrechtmäßige staatliche
subventionen einen eingriff in den
wettbewerb
die usa dürfen deshalb importe aus
ländern mit airbus standorten mit zellen
in höhe von siebeneinhalb milliarden
dollar belegen zum beispiel auf wein
oder käse aber insbesondere auf
flugzeuge und flugzeugteile ist das nun
eine hiobsbotschaft für die eu stefan
leifert oder kann sie sich wehren
also wenn us-präsident trump diese
strafzölle am ende wirklich lässt dann
hat die eu durchaus möglichkeiten sich
zu wehren denn dass der us-präsident
jetzt hier so eine art freifahrtschein
für strafzölle in milliarden-höhe
bekommt das ist nur eine seite der
geschichte
die andere seite der geschichte ist dass
die eu bald einen eben solchen
freifahrtschein auskennst bekommt denn
die welthandelsorganisation hat bereits
entschieden dass auch die subventionen
der us-regierung für den us
flugzeughersteller boeing unzulässig
waren und jetzt wird in wenigen wochen
die entscheidung darüber erwartet in
welcher milliarden-höhe die eu
ihrerseits strafzölle gegen amerika
verhängen darf die liste dafür liegt
hier in den schubladen der eu kommission
schon bereit spielzeug konsolen stehen
darauf tomatenketchup also eine liste in
großem umfang der us präsident hat es
also in der hand selbst zu entscheiden
die eskalation will oder verhandlungen
mit brüssel danke für ihre erläuterungen
stefan leifert in brüssel
der exit countdown läuft ende oktober
ist austrittstermin großbritanniens
premierminister johnson hat der eu ein
angebot unterbreitet und spricht von
einem kompromiss hauptstreitpunkt ist
nach wie vor die grenze zwischen der
republik irland und nordirland und die
frage wie harte grenzkontrollen
vermieden werden können
andreas stammen über johnsons ideen und
die reaktionen darauf
lange schlangen endlich aufbruch endlich
die praxis blockade lösen so die
hoffnung
johnsons erste rede als bringt
überschattet von korruption und
belästigungsvorwürfen der alte slogan
das land wird am 31 oktober die eu
verlassen koste es was es wolle
die neue tonlage am besten mit abkommen
deshalb legen wir heute in brüssel
vernünftige und konstruktive vorschläge
vor einen kompromiss
es wird so unter keinen umständen
kontrollen an oder nahe der grenze
zwischen irland und nordirland geben
die alternative ist ein brett ohne
abkommen was wir nicht wollen aber wir
sind bereit das laut johnson letzte
angebot trägt der britische chef
unterhändler am mittag nach brüssel der
kern der vorschläge sickert vorab durch
großbritannien will als ganzes die
europäische zoll union verlassen fordert
eine sonderregelung für den nordirischen
landesteil der im binnenmarkt bleiben
soll zeitlich beschränkt notwendige
zollformalitäten würden fernab der
grenze erledigt kompliziert illusorisch
unzureichend so die reaktion auf
europäischer seite etwas was ich bislang
gesehen habe ist nicht viel versprechend
erscheint keine basis seien abkommen
aber wir werden weiter miteinander
regeln wo wir aus quito king johnson ist
weit entfernt von einem deal am abend
signalisiert die eu-kommission immerhin
verhandlungsbereitschaft die partei
feiert ihren star
obwohl er seinen versprechen austritt
ende oktober keinen schritt näher ist
vor genau einem jahr wurde der saudische
journalist georgy ermordet und bis heute
ist die frage nach den auftraggebern
nicht geklärt laut uno gibt es
anhaltspunkte dass dahinter der
saudische kronprinz bin salman steht in
istanbul erinnerten freunde und
verwandte an den regimekritiker
sie forderten eine gründliche
untersuchung der schotte war dort im
saudi-arabischen konsulat ermordet
worden
schwerwiegender verdacht gegen zwei
thüringer polizisten
der vorwurf die beamten sollen während
ihres dienstes eine frau vergewaltigt
haben die staatsanwaltschaft erfurt
erließ haftbefehle
nach medienberichten soll sich die tat
während einer durchsuchung der wohnung
der frau ereignet haben
in hessen sind zwei menschen durch keime
in der wurst gestorben
daraufhin haben die behörden eine
wurstfabrik geschlossen und die produkte
weltweit zurückrufen
in der produktion der nordhessischen
firma sind mehrfach listerien
nachgewiesen worden
obwohl zwischendurch gereinigt worden
war listerien sind bakterien die
durchfall und fieber hervorrufen können
37 krankheitsfälle werden noch
untersucht
er war wohl der bekannteste und
beliebteste tscheche in deutschland und
das über jahrzehnte der schlagersänger
karel gott starb nun 80 jährige an
leukämie
mit seinen liedern eroberte er ein
millionenpublikum unvergessen sein
titellied zur kinderserie biene maja
mehr als 60 jahre stand er auf der bühne
an seinem stern
[Musik]
du weißt dass die herzen nie erlöschen
singt karel gott in diesem lied zusammen
mit charlotte einer seiner vier töchter
das war im mai die letzte aufnahme der
schlager superstar liebte die musik bis
zum schluss eine einzige richtige feste
lebens bindung ist die bühne sein leben
beginnt 1939 in pilsen die familie zieht
später nach prag karel wird
elektrotechniker und er sinkt in
tanzcafés wird er entdeckt studiert
schließlich gesang und wird zum star
internationale erfolge vor allem auch in
deutschland der hit biene maja
[Musik]
karel gott für viele eine legende jetzt
ist die goldene stimme aus prag
verstummt
[Musik]
tja traurig und uns die erneuert und so
fußball-champions-league mit viel licht
und viel schatten gestern abend für die
deutschen vereine
dunkle wolken in leverkusen nach dem 0
zu 3 bei juventus turin
die zweite niederlage im zweiten
gruppenspiel dagegen eitel sonnenschein
bei bayern münchen nach dem
sensationellen 7 2 auswärtssieg über
tottenham glückliche große spieler sind
manchmal wie kleine kinder sehr stabil
und niklas süle aber das war auch weil
er mir einen schlag gegeben hat ich weiß
nicht warum müssen wir nochmal klären
aber das ist heute abend muss ich sagen
freue ich mich unglaublich ein sehr sehr
guter freund von mir deswegen noch umso
mehr hat er sich verdient
es ist eine gnade gala gegen tottenham
vier sehenswerte treffer gelingen dem
24-jährigen auswärts hat das noch kein
deutscher spieler in der champions
league geschafft
es sind cabrios erste tore überhaupt in
der königsklasse
mein essen 46 tore direkt an einem tag
zu erzielen und natürlich grandios und
beste spiel meiner karriere weil ich
nicht glaube schon einige gute aber
heute war es denke ich mit vier toren
eines der besten
nach anfänglichen bayern problemen gegen
tottenham treffen auch josua kimmig und
zweimal robert lewandowski gegen den
letztjährigen
champions-league-finalisten 72 ein
großer sieg nachdem sich der vierfach
torschütze in ganz besonderes andenken
mit nach hause nimmt
gestern aufregung um die deutsche
medaillenhoffnung constanze
klosterhalfen wegen der doping-sperre
ihres cheftrainers sala sah in den usa
sie selbst sprach im zdf von einer
schockierenden nachricht heute aber
freude und erleichterung bei der
leverkusenerin denn sie qualifizierte
sich bei der leichtathletik wm in doha
durch ihren zweiten platz im vorlauf
über 5000 meter für das finale und
zeigte eine souveräne
und das finale über 5000 meter dann am
samstag und wir haben noch die zahlen
vom mittwoch slaughter die gewinnzahlen
lauten 3 26 29 31 33 48 und die
superzahl 0
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
das feiertags wetter wird nicht überall
schön wo die sonne aber scheint und wo
es regnet das erfahren sie gleich von
essent erli so viel von uns schön dass
sie dabei waren
marietta slomka informiert sie im heute
journal um 22 uhr
und wir sind morgen wieder für sie da
punkt 19 war es bislang